[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas chez un fleuriste
mais dans le lieu de vente de deux
créatrices des fleurs séchées de l'ap la
céramique décoration et arts de la table
et des belles plantes vertes d'intérieur
un projet d'ouverture motivée par les
deux confinement les gens étaient
coincés chez eux ils avaient envie de
nouveauté de s'occuper de leur intérieur
de touche verte d'avoir plus de contacts
avec la nature du coup on a très bien
fonctionné et ça nous a énormément
encouragé pour ouvrir une boutique
malgré le contexte actuel boutique mais
pas seulement
amandine et chloé ont chacune leur
propre atelier objectif avoir plus de
visibilité en créant directement sur
place
cash en train dé mallet mes pièces donc
c'est une des étapes en fait de la de la
céramique où les marchés sont un peu en
stand by en ce moment et que on a moins
de possibilité de pouvoir exposer le
fait d'avoir voilà notre propre boutique
atelier parent mais voilà de que le
monde vienne à nous si on ne peut pas
forcément aller dans des lieux prévus
pour et les créatrices ne s'arrête pas
là c'est trop on voit des petites billes
elle propose aussi des ateliers
découverte on va planter les petites
plantes dans le bocal et vous savez
comment ça s'appelle un terrarium
je me suis dit moi ça peut être sympa
pour eux et puis les occuper leur faire
découvrir quelque chose qu'on a pas
l'habitude de faire à la maison et puis
qui ont marqué à l'air de leur plaire
donc c'est tout gagné
anodine et chloé pense déjà à du nouveau
projet proposé leurs services dans
l'événementiel comme un pied de nez à la
crise sanitaire